안녕하세요. 기술로트 알렉입니다.
저는 25년차 IT 업계에서 개발 관련된 일을 하고 있습니다.
오늘은 40대, 50대 분들도 이제 바이브 코딩 말로 하는 개발이죠.
이것을 해야 하는 이후 3가지 그리고 후반부에서는 10분 내로 AI 개발 바이브 코딩을 실습하는 내용을 말씀드리도록 하겠습니다.
첫 번째는 생존 문제입니다.
제 지인 중에 10년차 회계사가 있어서 물었습니다.
이 AI가 도입되면서 본인의 업무에 어떤 여행이 있는지 물어봤습니다.
최 GPT를 아주 잘 쓰고 있고 기존보다 업무를 좀 더 편하게 하고 있다라고 답변을 해주었습니다.
그리고 본인의 포지션에 여행이 있는지에 대해서도 물어보았습니다.
거의 없다 라고 답을 했습니다.
그런데 여기서 이제 신입을 거의 뽑고 있지 않고 업무를 보조하고 있었던 직원들도 거의 채용이 없다 라고 답을 했습니다.
바이브 코딩이라는 걸 들어봤는지 또는 해봤는지 물어보았습니다.
들어봤다고 하더라고요. 그리고 어떤 것인지 알고 있다.
아직은 해보지는 않았다. 그런데 옆 직원은 바이브 코딩을 해서 업무 자동화라고 있고 간단한 프로그램을 만들어서 쓰고 있다 라고 얘기를 해 주었습니다.
저는 여기서 핵심은 AI를 활용하는 것이 단순히 과거의 최 GPT를 물어보고 답변 받는 거에서 조금씩 자동화를 하고 프로그램 만든 영역으로 좀 더 확대되고 있다라는 느낌을 받았습니다.
업무의 AI를 활용하는 것이 늘고 있고 생존을 위한 필수 도가 되고 있는데 그 필수 도구의 영역이 좀씩 늘고 있다.
결국 살아남는 사람은 누굴까요?
빠른 은퇴에 대한 얘기입니다. 뉴스를 통해서 들어보셨겠지만 우리나라 평균 은퇴나이 49세.
그리고 어쩌면 더 빨라지고 있습니다. 그리고 원치 않은 은퇴를 당할 수도 있습니다.
뭐 하실.. 사업? 자영업? 더 큰 손해일 수도 있습니다.
만만치 않습니다. 그렇다고 아무것도 하지 않는 것이 답인가요?
그런데 여기서 한번 생각해볼 솔루션이 있습니다. 사업이 아니고 자영업이 아니고 자기가 어떤 경력을 쌓아온 사람이라면 자기만의 업이 있었다면
자기가 업무하면서 한번쯤은 내가 업무할 때 이런 시스템이 있었으면 이런 서비스가 있었으면 이런 어떤 도구가 있었으면 어떤 프로그램이 있었으면 하는 생각을 한두 번쯤 해봤을 것입니다.
그 경력자들이 알고 있는 그 업을 해본 사람만이 알고 있는 그 현장에서의 틈색. 그것이 경력자가 할 수 있는 그 업을 해본 사람만이 할 수 있는 그런 내용이고
제가 말씀드리는 이 바이브 코딩은 자본이 들지 않습니다. 외주를 구할 필요도 없구요. 외주의 속 썩일 일도 없습니다.
바이브 코딩을 통해서 본인이 직접 만들 수가 있습니다. 바이브 코딩은 사실은 배우는 영역이 아닙니다. 그냥 해보는 겁니다.
심지어 제 지인 중에 비정공자가 있는데요. 최근에 무슨 일을 하는지 한번 물었을 때 그 친구가 개발 강의를 하고 있다라고 답을 해줬습니다.
그래서 저는 너무 궁금해서 그 친구는 비정공자인데 어떻게 개발 강의를 하는지 물었더니 요즘 바이브 코딩 강의를 하고 있다라고 하더라구요.
그래서 저도 웃고 그 친구도 웃었습니다. 서로 웃는 가운데 제가 그럼 뭘 가르치냐라고 물었을 때
바이브 코딩 하는 거 어떻게 하는지 알려주고 있다라고 했는데 대부분이 40, 50대 분들이고 또 하나는 사실상 가르쳐줄 게 별로 없다라고 했습니다.
근데 그때 저는 그 말을 충분히 공감을 했습니다. 어? 배울 게 아니라 그냥 해보면 되는데? 라는 생각을 했던 것이죠.
그래서 비정공자 그 친구는 지금 바이브 코딩 강사입니다. 가르치기 없다 라는 말이 맞습니다. 그냥 됩니다. 해보면 되는 거죠.
마치 누구나 웹서핑이나 인터넷 엑셀을 쓸 수 있듯이 말이죠. 바이브 코딩 도구에 관련된 얘기들도 많이 있는데요.
일단은 제가 추천드리는 툴은 커서 ai 입니다. 제가 여러 가지 도구를 써봤는데 인문용으로는 가장 좋습니다.
지금 그냥 맛 먹고 10분 인생의 10분 그렇게 긴 시간은 아닙니다. 그래서 한번 투자해 가지고 끝까지 한번 보시고 이렇게 한번 맛 보시면 그다음부터는 맘껏 무엇이든지 할 수가 있습니다.
먼저 구글에서 커서 ai 이렇게 치겠습니다. 커서 ai를 치면요. 첫 번째 커서.com이 나와요. 커서.com
그럼 여기서 다운로드 4 윈도우스 또는 자기 환경에 맞게 다운로드를 받습니다.
저는 윈도우 환경이어서 다운로드를 이걸 그대로 봤습니다. 혹시 맥을 사용하신 분들은 맥 버전을 받으시면 되겠습니다.
자 다운로드 받은 EX-A를 그대로 실행을 하셔가지고
동의하기 누르고 다음 설치. 그러면 쭉 진행이 되고요. 사실 커서 설치만으로 어느 정도 이제 바이브 코딩에 들어가시는 상황이다라고 보시면 됩니다.
저는 기존 프렉트가 하나 올라와 있어서 이렇게 떴는데요. 처음 설치하면 이렇게 해서 오픈 폴더를 선택을 합니다.
여기서 세 폴더 해 가지고
저는 바이브 코딩이라고 바이브 언더 코딩이라고 폴더를 하나 만들었어요. 폴더 이름은 자유롭게 만드셔도 됩니다.
다만 이제 거기에 소스들이나 이런 분들이 생길 거예요. 이렇게 하나 생기면 아직까지 파일이 아무것도 없어요.
보시면 이제 이쪽 화면
이쪽이 뉴챗이라고 되어 있는데 여기가 AI와 대화하는 곳이라고 보시면 되고요. 이 대화를 하게 되면 여기에 응답도 찍히고
이쪽에 코드도 생성이 됩니다.
그래서 여기에서 그냥 기존의 채 GPT에서 하셨듯이 동일하게 하시면 되고요. 개발 관련된 요청들을 하시면 돼요.
아주 간단한 거 항상 개발의 시작은 거의 헬로우 월드였는데
이렇게 한번 요청을 해보겠습니다.
그렇게 되면 여기 AI가 쭉 만들고 있는 거예요. 간단하게 이미 만들었네요. 굉장히 빠르죠.
여기서 실제 파일로
만들어 달라고 좀 할게요.
아까는 채 GPT처럼 여기에 응답만 줬고요. 지금 이렇게 하니까 여기에 생성이 됐습니다. 이렇게 해서 소스가 하나 완성이 됐죠.
여기에 이제 바이브 코딩 시작이다 라고 보셔도 됩니다. 그런 브라운에서 현재 현재 프로젝트에서 생긴 인덱스 파일을 이렇게 가져오면 보여지고요.
여기 내에도 요거를 클릭해서 오픈 리스 라이브 서버 이런 걸로도 볼 수가 있습니다.
그러면 그 자체 서버에서 뛰어서 이 파일을 보여주는 거죠. 이건 기본적으로 웹이기 때문에 서버에서 구동된다라는 개념을 조금 이해하시면
도움이 됩니다. 저희 요 관련되서도 조금 기술적인 내용들은 제 차 계속 설명을 드릴 거예요. 그런데 바이브 코딩 들어오면서는 기술을 다 이해하고 요걸 하는 것 보다는 하에 가면서 기술을 보는 것이 훨씬 더 빠를 겁니다.
바이브 코딩은 이제 이런 거의 반복이에요. 이제 만들어 줬잖아요. 그러면 여기서 원하는 것들을 계속 만들어 가는 겁니다.
이런 식으로 해서 만약에 여기서 조금 팁이 될 수 있는데요. 내가 만들고자 하는 사이트가 내가 아주 비슷한 사이트가 좀 있다. 그러면 이렇게 가져올 수도 있어요.
구글 사이트 같은 것들을 좀 비슷하게 만들고자 한다고 하면 캡쳐을 할 수 있죠. 요거를 캡쳐해 가지고 캡쳐 도구는 자체 내장되어 있습니다. 윈도우 같은 경우는 여기서 보시면
캡쳐 라고 쓰시면 돼요. 캡쳐 도구 뜹니다. 여기서 이렇게 해 가지고 그냥 이렇게 긁어야돼요.
이렇게 해 가지고 복사 해 가지고 여기에 넣으시면 됩니다.
이번에는 지금 첨부한 이미지 같은 UI 화면을
만들어 줘. 이렇게 할 수 있어요.
보시면 요 첨부 조금 깨졌지만 여기 그냥 컨트롤 C 컨트롤 V 한 거예요. 이것을 첨부 이미지와 같은 UI 화면을 만들어줘 라고 했습니다. 그러면 이제 AI가
이제 요거를 만들기 위한 작업들을 합니다. 여기서 조금 말씀을 먼저 드리면 html css 이게 만약에 동적인 기능들 포함한다 포함해야 된다. 그럼 잡았을 때까지 생성이 되는 거죠.
맞춰졌고요. 이게 맞춰졌다고 이제 멘트가 나오면 끝난 겁니다. 시간은 좀 걸려요. 그 상태에서 요거를 한 번 또 보겠습니다.
어 이게 지금 만들어진 거거든요. 아직 기능은 동작되지 않는데 이 정도 UI로 만들어졌네요.
그런데 일단은 여기 지금 자체 서버에 띄운 거고 이렇게 만들어진 거예요. 이게 좀 중요한 힌트가 될 수 있고요.
만들고자 하는 데서 조금 차관을 해 가지고 가져와서 그대로 만들어 달라고 하면 돼요. 지금 클란트 화면만 만들어진 거예요. 요 개념하고 서버 개념 이런 것들을 좀 이해하시면 이제 차차 만들어 가시면 되거든요.
일단 만들고자 하는 화면들을 만드는 게 저는 1단계라고 생각을 합니다. 그래서 이렇게 만들어 본 거고 제가 이 클란트 서버 개념 조금 설명드리고 또 차차 더 설명을 드릴게요.
그 요거 기술로트 pdf인데 이번에 이미지도 전체 한 번 다 업데이트 했어요. 일단 클란트에서 요기 웹으로 접속하는 개념 요걸 좀 이해를 하시면 웹 어플리케이션을 만들 때 좀 도움이 되시는데 일단 웹이라는 개념은 웹 서버라는 게 존재합니다. 웹 서버라는 게 존재하고
와스까지는 요거 다음에 설명을 또 드릴게요. 데이터베이스도 마찬가지고 웹만 또 심플하게 놓고 봤을 때 클란트는 방금 브라우저
브라우저고요. 특정 URL를 가지고 이렇게 접속을 하죠. 서버에 네이버.com 구글.com 이렇게 접속을 하죠. 그게 URL이고 이 URL로 찾아 들어가서 서버를 만나면 서버는 특정 응답을 이렇게 해줍니다.
그 응답이 html이 담겨 있는 거예요. 당연히 css도 담겨져 있고요. javascript까지 담겨져 있습니다.
이렇게 담겨져 있는 데이터가 이 브라우저로 전송이 되고 브라우저에서는 그 이 이러한 형태의 html가 css로 형 만들어진 그런 문서가 보여지는 그런 상황이다 라고 보시면 됩니다.
자 그래서 html css라면 보면요. 여기서 또 소스보기를 할 수가 있어요. 소스보기
페이지 원본 보기 하면 이렇게 나와 있는데 이게 html입니다. html를 시작해서 html로 쭉 되고 여기서부터 이렇게 나오는 것들이 스타일 안에 있는 것이 css라는 거예요.
화면을 꾸며주는 언어 그리고 여기는 html. 그래서 html로 쭉 되어 있고 이렇게 꾸며주는 언어로 또 되어 있는 겁니다.
그래서 이런 것들로 화면이 만들어진다라고 보시면 됩니다. 결국 이 html 하나에서 이 화면을 쭉 만들어 놓은 거죠.
이렇게 화면을 만들 수가 있다는 거고요. 바이브 코딩이라는 것이 이렇게 말로 개발을 할 수 있다라는 개념이고요.
좀 쉽게 생각하시면 이렇게 시작하시면 되고 지금 일단 화면을 이런 식으로 만든다 정도를 했고 이후에 서버도 만들어 보고 데이터베이스도 만드는 것도 충분히 다 가능하시기 때문에
이런 식의 영상 좀 도움이 되셨다 하시면 좋아요를 눌러주세요. 그럼 제가 이후에 영상들도 꾸준히 연속해서 올리도록 하겠습니다. 또 좋은 내용으로 찾아뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.